[Music]
Augusta Ada Lovelace feared she had
inherited her father's Madness she was
named after her dad's half-sister with
whom he had an affair when Ada's mother
Annabella Milbank suspected her husband
was involved in an incestuous
relationship she rejected her daughter's
first name and henceforth called her by
her middle name
Ada's father was a great British poet
Lord Byron he was as famous for his
Playboy life as he was for his poetry he
had numerous Affairs including with Lady
Caroline lamb who described him as mad
bad and dangerous to know and he was
five weeks after the birth of ADA lady
Byron left Lord Byron Lord Byron wrote
about seeing his daughter for the last
time in his famous poem child Herald's
pilgrimage when I last saw thy young
blue eyes they smiled and then we parted
Ada never saw her father again when she
was eight he caught a terrible cold
which worsened after he allowed his
doctors to purge his blood even though
he was against it shortly after Lord
Byron died his final words were said to
be oh my poor dear child my dear Ada my
God could I have seen her give her my
blessing there was a portrait of Lord
Byron at Ada's home but her mother kept
it hidden behind a green curtain and Ada
never saw it until she was 20 years old
apparently it was to protect it from
smoke rather than because of Byron's
reputation but lady Byron wanted to make
sure Ada didn't turn out like her father
so she decided to have Ada rigorously
tutored in mathematics thinking it would
be the best antidote to her
rebelliousness that was unusual for a
woman in the 19th century then again
Ada's mother had herself been tutored in
math by a former professor of Cambridge
University despite lady Byron's efforts
to ensure Ada didn't follow the same
Wayward path as her father Ada ended up
having an affair as a teen with one of
her tutors and then tried to run away
from home to be with him Lord Byron
never wanted his daughter to turn out
like him he once wrote a letter to his
half-sister Augusta to see if she could
find out what Ada was like Byron wrote I
hope the gods have made her anything
save poetical it is enough to have one
such Fool In The Family
Ada loved poetry but she also loved math
she felt it was the only language that
can adequately Express the great facts
of the natural world and it is the
instrument through which the weak mind
of man can most effectually read his
Creator's Works after the scandalous
affair with her tutor she decided to get
her act together and declared to her new
tutor I must cease to think of living
for pleasure or self-gratification I
find that nothing but very close and
intense application to subjects of a
scientific nature now seems to keep my
imagination from running wild it was the
perfect time to immerse herself in
science and technology Ada was born in
1815 at the height of the Industrial
Revolution in Britain she was fascinated
by the factories popping up in central
England this was in contrast to her
father who defended the British textile
workers who felt threatened by the new
technology and destroyed the machinery
Ada was particularly impressed by an
automated machine that wove patterns on
fabric the jacquer loom used punched
cards to create designs the design is
translated into a pattern of holes
punched into cards the cards direct the
pattern of the weave automating the
creation of complex designs this
transformed textile manufacturing in the
future Punch Cards would also control a
sequence of operations in early
computers one of Britain's few noted
female mathematicians took Ada under her
Wing Mary Somerville became a friend
teacher and mentor Somerville introduced
her to Charles Babbage an esteemed
English mathematician who had an
interest in machines that could perform
human tasks Ada grew fascinated by
babbage's idea to build an analytical
engine a mechanical computer that would
use a series of gears and wheels to
perform mathematical calculations in
babbage's mind it could perform any kind
of calculation based on the programming
instructions given to it this was more
advanced than his Difference Engine
which was like a big basic mechanical
calculator that could only perform a
specific kind of calculation while the
analytical engine was designed to
perform a wider range of mathematical
calculations in the way that the Punch
Cards directed the loom to weave designs
on fabric Punch Cards would program the
Computing machine Lovelace made the
connection between the two writing this
beautiful description the analytical
engine weaves algebraic patterns just
says the Jacob Loom weaves flowers and
leaves poetry flowed through her veins
as it did through her father's
she was comfortable in both worlds the
Arts and the Sciences which allowed her
to see the beauty in the mechanics of a
Computing machine Ada published a
description of babbage's analytical
engine in a British science journal in
1843.
this was partly a translation of a
French work though her own additional
notes ended up being twice as long as
the original she gave step-by-step
instructions on how the machine could
calculate a sequence of Bernoulli
numbers which are mathematical constants
used in many areas of mathematics this
is considered to be the first published
algorithm which is why she's often
referred to as the world's first
computer programmer Babbage saw his
analytical engine as primarily a machine
that crunched numbers however Ada felt
it could be so much more she saw it as a
general purpose machine that could
process anything that could be written
using symbols she believed it could
create poetry and make music writing the
engine might compose elaborate and
scientific pieces of music of any degree
of complexity she imagined the world's
first computer 100 years before the
first ones were built in World War II
there was one other interesting Concept
in her scientific paper
she raised the idea of whether machines
could think Ada believed they could not
she felt a machine could perform
operations as instructed but has no
pretensions whatever to originate
anything
British mathematician Alan Turing
refuted this a century later he was
famous for cracking the Nazi machine
that encrypted top secret messages
turing's 1950 paper had a section dubbed
lady lovelace's objection he wrote a
better variant of the objection says
that a machine can never take us by
surprise machines take me by surprise
with great frequency he believed that a
machine might be able to learn and
therefore be able to generate new
thoughts his famous test proposed that a
computer can be said to be intelligent
if it can convince a person that it's
having a conversation with another human
being but even if a machine could
successfully mimic human thinking his
critics argued it would not really be
conscious a machine would lack
comprehension or awareness of what it
was saying this is still the most
debated Topic in cognitive science
AI does not currently possess the
Consciousness or awareness that humans
do or at least that's what chat GPT told
me when I asked it if only Ada could
have seen what computers are now capable
of
when I uploaded the only known
photograph of her into the AI tool Dolly
it generated new images
Ada wanted to enter into a formal
business relationship with Babbage with
the aim of building the analytical
engine she offered to use her
Connections in persuasive penmanship to
gain funding for his engine if she could
control the business decisions she
believed Babbage would for sure take the
deal writing to her mother that he will
probably yield
unfortunately for her Babbage did not
yield unfortunately for him he never got
the funding he needed to build his
machine and he died broke
Ada lovelace's life would spiral
downhill she struggled with ill health
for years and her health deteriorated
further after she completed her
scientific paper which was the only
paper she ever published she took
opiates to treat her pain and became
addicted which led to mood swings and
Illusions she also became addicted to
gambling and lost thousands of pounds
betting on the wrong horse in a race and
had to pawn some of her family's Jewels
her finances dwindled despite the fact
she had married the socially prominent
William King who inherited the noble
title Earl of Lovelace making her
Countess of Lovelace she had three
children and named her first son Byron
after the father she never knew
it's widely believed that Lord Byron
also fathered a child with his own
half-sister
this didn't come as a shock to Ada who
wrote to her mother I am not in the
least astonished but she didn't blame
her father and instead called his
half-sister inherently Wicked she was
fascinated by her father and believed
she had inherited his genius which she
vowed to use to bring out great truths
and principles I think he has bequeathed
this task to me
sadly her life was cut short she
suffered from uterine cancer and died on
November 27 1852 at the age of 36. at
her request she was buried in a small
English town next to her father who died
at the same age
in 1991 Science Museum London built
babbage's Difference Engine from his
original drawings as for the analytical
engine partial sections of it were built
which Ada had the opportunity to see
herself however there are no plans to
recreate it in full
Ada Lovelace is celebrated as a computer
Pioneer the U.S defense department even
named a programming language after her
long before anyone else Ada lovelies
realized the true potential of computers
and paved the path for our digital age
if you're looking to improve your own
skills in computer science
brilliant.org is a website and app where
you can learn stem interactively my
viewers especially love the computer
science courses which are really
Hands-On and fun so it doesn't even feel
like learning brilliant is great for
both beginners and those who want to
improve on what they already know which
is crucial in today's world to help you
stay ahead as you progress through their
lessons you can dive deeper into more
advanced topics I personally use
brilliant to boost my analytical
thinking skills by going through their
logic puzzles brilliant supports you
every step of the way if you're stuck
you can view the explanation to see
where you went wrong there are thousands
of lessons to choose from everything
from foundational in advanced math to
data science and it's free for you to
try out for 30 days if you head to my
custom link in the description
brilliant.org newsthink and the first
200 people who sign up with my link will
get 20 off their annual subscription